dans un commerce je tombe et je me
blesse est-ce que je peux recevoir de
l'argent pour ça plein de gens nous
posent cette question quiconque a été
négligent ou imprudents doit réparer un
dommage causé à autrui c'est ce qu'on
appelle la responsabilité civile alors
si vous avez glissé sur une fraise
écrasée à l'épicerie voici la question
que vous devrez vous poser parce que
c'est simple juge doit se demander en
cours pour éviter une telle situation
aurait fait un épicier raisonnable si la
vidéo de surveillance montrent que
personne ne nettoyer le plancher depuis
plusieurs heures si des témoins
confirment que des fraises traîner par
terre depuis longtemps vous pourrez
peut-être démontrer une faute de la part
de l'épicier le critère de l'ifi si
raisonnable peut faire toute la
différence entre une personne indemniser
une personne qui ne l'est pas s'ils ont
conclu à la faute les frais médicaux la
cote de salaires mais aussi les douleur
et la souffrance morale peuvent donner
droit à une indemnisation vous avez
trois ans pour entamer des démarches
selon la loi québécoise mais attention
selon la loi ontarienne vous avez deux
ans passés le mot coup
[Musique]